[Music]
so today we are here is very exciting
event we're doing an autograph session
for all the players at the stinkbug cup
people come from all over the world to
come see this and get signatures we come
from Oklahoma but we actually live in
Indonesia Magnus is my favorite champion
in the whole world I'm going to get his
autograph today I came from Madison
Wisconsin to get some signatures from
the world's best motors I never know how
often I'll get to see you know meet
these people get the signature it could
be once in a lifetime for all
supplemental California and we my son is
really into the 10th yeah this is the
one of the UN he does not want to miss
what mostly mattress Carlson so he's the
world champion but we had a family
reunion in Tulsa Oklahoma it was about
five hours away so we said hey we can
just do this and we're meeting the top
players in the world actually an on I
don't know he's just like he's someone I
followed for a long time of course and
but really any of them they're fabulous
players
this is like my first time meeting him
in a real person for nine years I've
been waiting great that all of them can
be here make the time for for 39 year
olds and nine year olds as well I mean
this is a dad son trip for me it's worth
it just to be a bystander kind of look
at what you know what it's like yeah I
was nervous meeting the champion of
chess all the world
kogai
[Music]